This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不安全、无法公开的坦诚对话。但在这里，你是与一位深谙此道的有执照专业人士一同交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲？这向世界传递出的信号是：别想招惹我。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你必须这么做，请在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
收听《艰难抉择》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echerd）被指控使人生下双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。英文是TWA percent。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners,
相信你的闺蜜。请在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（The girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听众，老听众，
wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today, we're going to talk about alcohol. The impact of alcohol on our minds, the influence our social circles and friendships have on our drinking habits, anxiety, binge drinking, all the conversations about how, alcohol that we should be having in our 20s that maybe we are not. Obviously, as we are talking,
无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目。今天，我们要聊聊酒精。酒精对我们心灵的影响，我们的社交圈和友谊对我们饮酒习惯的影响，焦虑，酗酒，所有这些我们在二十岁时本该讨论、却可能并未讨论的关于酒精的话题。显然，正如我们在交谈时所知，
we have just entered into a new year. And a lot of us are probably considering the ways that we can be healthier, happier, more fulfilled, whether that's eating more vegetables, exercising more, journaling, turning off our screens, or perhaps rethinking our drinking habits. I think this generation is a lot more educated and aware of the role that alcohol plays in our lives, both good and bad, and just genuinely more sober curious, more willing to question the relationship with drinking or abstain entirely. It's really interesting because when I was researching this episode, I came across this series of economic papers of like financial reports about Japan. and how in Japan at the moment, they're actually running a series of commercials to promote drinking amongst younger people
我们刚刚进入新的一年。我们中的许多人可能都在思考如何让自己变得更健康、更快乐、更充实，不管是多吃蔬菜、多锻炼、写日记、放下屏幕，还是重新审视我们的饮酒习惯。我认为这一代人对酒精在我们生活中扮演的角色（无论是好是坏）有了更多的教育和认知，而且普遍对无酒精饮品更加好奇，更愿意质疑自己与饮酒的关系，或者完全戒酒。这真的很有趣，因为在研究这期节目时，我偶然看到了一系列关于日本的经济论文和财务报告，
because so many people in this generation are really questioning the pervasiveness of alcohol in our lives, the fact that we drink without thinking twice whether it is worth it. And this question of should I quit drinking or at least limit my alcohol intake has been on my mind a lot recently, especially since quite a few of my friends have started cutting out alcohol from their lives, and are really seeing some insane benefits to their mental well-being, the quality of their relationships, their fitness, even their skin. One of my best friends, Sarah, was really the inspiration for this episode because she is in that very boat at the moment.
内容是关于目前日本正在推出一系列广告来向年轻人推广饮酒，因为这一代人中有太多人真正在质疑酒精在我们生活中的无处不在，质疑我们是否不加思索地饮酒，甚至不去想这到底是否值得。我最近一直在思考“我是不是该戒酒，或者至少限制酒精摄入量”这个问题，尤其是因为我的好几个朋友最近都开始在生活中戒酒了，并且真切地看到了他们心理健康、人际关系质量、体能甚至是皮肤方面的惊人改善。我最好的朋友之一萨拉，真的是这期节目的灵感来源，因为她目前就处于这种状态中。
She quit drinking for a few months. and when she told me my first reaction was like how how is this possible and my second thought was I could never do that that would be way too hard for me that would be impossible no chance I literally have a tattoo of a glass of wine on my wrist alcohol it's such a deeply ingrained part of my life but at what cost is that coming at at what cost and it was these kind of knee jerk thoughts that really caused me to pause for a second and reconsider whether my drinking habits were actually healthy or it would actually be that hard for me to quit. And if it would be that hard for me to quit, impossible, even as I'd initially thought, what was to distinguish between
她戒酒几个月了，当她告诉我的时候，我的第一反应是“怎么可能，这怎么办得到”；而我的第二个反应是“我绝对做不到，这对我来说太难了，这绝无可能，根本没机会”。我的手腕上甚至真的纹了一个酒杯，酒精已经成了我生活中根深蒂固的一部分。但这一切的代价是什么？究竟是以什么为代价？正是这种膝跳反射般的想法，让我停下来思考了一秒钟，重新评估我的饮酒习惯是否真的健康，或者戒酒对我来说是不是真的那么难。如果戒酒对我来说真的那么难，甚至如我最初所想的那样根本不可能，那么
me and someone addicted to alcohol, clinically addicted? You know, maybe my drinking habits are a bit more socially acceptable. I don't drink at inappropriate times. I'm not drinking to the point of being hung over every day. But just because it's more socially acceptable doesn't mean it's not a problem or there isn't still kind of an underlying emotional or physical dependence occurring there. So it was here that I really began to look back at the past few months and ask myself, you know, when was the last time I didn't drink at least every second day of the week? And I really, I could not answer the question. I genuinely couldn't remember. My life, the way I socialize, the way I unwind, the way I celebrate, even just relax, it is all centered on the presence of alcohol. And I think that
我和那些对酒精上瘾的人、临床上瘾的人之间有什么区别？你知道的，也许我的饮酒习惯在社会上更容易被接受。我不在不合时宜的时候喝酒。我没有每天喝到宿醉的程度。但仅仅因为它在社会上更容易被接受，并不意味着它就不是一个问题，或者其中没有正在发生的潜在情感或身体依赖。所以正是在这里，我真正开始回顾过去的几个月，问自己：你知道吗，我上一次连续至少每两天不喝酒是什么时候？说实话，我回答不出这个问题。我真的记不起来了。我的生活，我的社交方式，我放松的方式，我庆祝的方式，甚至仅仅是放松一下，全部都是围绕着酒精的存在展开的。而且我认为，
that is the case for many of us in our 20s, especially as we enter into full-time work, or those around us also start working full-time. Most of the time that we reserve to see, each other to hang out is during the evenings. And what do we do when we want to socialize in the evenings? We go out for a drink. Or we go out for dinner and we get a bottle of wine or we get a beer. And then on the weekends, it's the same thing. We want to unwind. Alcohol naturally does that for us. It's this temporary stress release. And I think that has been really contributing to a lot of drinking habits that are quite second nature, that we don't actually really consider. There's also just this whole culture of drinking, especially where I live.
对于我们许多处于二十岁的人来说，情况确实如此，特别是当我们开始全职工作，或者身边的人也开始全职工作时。我们预留出来见面、一起闲逛的大部分时间都是在傍晚。而当我们在傍晚想要社交时，我们会做些什么？我们出去喝一杯。或者我们出去吃晚饭，点一瓶葡萄酒或喝杯啤酒。到了周末，也是如此。我们想要放松。酒精很自然地就能为我们做到这一点。这是一种暂时的压力释放。我认为这确实促成了很多几乎成了第二天性、而我们实际上并没有真正深思熟虑的饮酒习惯。此外，这里还存在着一种整个饮酒文化，尤其是在我居住的地方。
I live in Australia, obviously, and we're notorious for this. You know, Australians drink so much alcohol is part of the social fabric to have a beer after work, to have a beer with dinner, to have a beer with friends. And so the question just kept coming up, could I stop? not do I want to stop, but could I? And that right there is actually what we call being sober curious, thinking about your decisions to drink rather than just going along with social pressures, slowly finding ways to cut back, exploring what life could be without alcohol.
显然，我住在澳大利亚，我们因这一点而“闻名”。你知道的，澳大利亚人喝很多酒，下班后喝杯啤酒、晚饭时喝杯啤酒、和朋友喝杯啤酒，这些都是社交结构的一部分。所以这个问题不断浮现：我能停下来吗？不是我“想不想”停下来，而是我“能不能”？而这恰恰就是我们所说的“无酒精好奇”（sober curious）——思考你的饮酒决定，而不是盲目顺从社会压力，慢慢寻找减少饮酒量的方法，探索没有酒精的生活会是什么样。
Because even though alcohol is very omnipresent in our society and the way we interact with our friends, at the end of the day, it is still a drug. I saw this quote and it really changed my perspective on this. Alcohol is the only drug that causes generational trauma that is still culturally tolerated and celebrated. And I believe that many of us perhaps just go along with drinking culture because we don't really know any differently because alcohol makes us feel good because we are worried what we would have to give up in our social life. if we chose to stop. So let's explore that today. Let's explore the question of should I quit drinking in my 20s? If you are sober curious like me, this is definitely the episode for you because I'm exploring the same time that you are. So without further ado, I say we jump into all of the psychology, the biology, the
因为尽管酒精在我们的社会中以及在我们与朋友互动的方式中无处不在，但归根结底，它仍然是一种毒品。我看到过这样一句话，它真正改变了我对此的看法：酒精是唯一一种会导致代际创伤、却在文化上仍然被容忍和庆祝的毒品。我相信，我们中的许多人之所以顺应饮酒文化，或许只是因为我们不知道还有什么别的选择，因为酒精让我们感觉良好，或者是因为我们担心如果选择停下来，我们在社交生活中将不得不放弃什么。所以今天让我们来探讨一下。让我们探讨一下“我在二十岁时应该戒酒吗”这个问题。如果你和我一样对无酒精充满好奇，这绝对是适合你的节目，因为我也在和你一起探索。废话不多说，让我们直接切入所有这些行为背后的心理学、生物学、
physiology behind why we drink, what alcohol does to our minds and our bodies. And some of the reasons for quitting. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
生理学——为什么我们喝酒，酒精对我们的心灵和身体做了什么，以及戒酒的一些理由。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上具有炎症性。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。英文是T-W-O-Percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小肯姆（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crime. crack.
乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at it）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集节目中，我们都会来到这里，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那一切的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。需要明确的是，84年对我很重大，不仅仅是因为犯罪。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
快克。我随时都能谈论快克，但只是想让你们大家知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你补充完那句话。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month,
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难抉择》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却仍在追逐。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在记分牌上盯着看。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在人间时做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now.
而且那是两个不同信任级别。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），在我的新播客《艰难抉择》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用，搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法律战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改过测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们将揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人：格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Alcohol is, like we said, a drug. And why it makes us feel so good and more relaxed and more sociable comes down to its impact on our central nervous system.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得以伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。正如我们所说，酒精是一种药物。为什么它能让我们感觉如此美妙、更加放松、更加善于社交，这归结于它对我们中枢神经系统的影响。
So drugs come into forms, depressants and stimulants. So stimulants are things like ecstasy or cocaine. They make us more active and energetic and focused, whereas alcohol is a depressant. It slows down our brain activity, our movements. It makes us less anxious because it impacts the ways that messages travel between our body and our brain. So when we have a glass of wine, for example, contained in that glass of wine is ethanol. ethanol. Ethanol is a psychoactive substance that is metabolized by our body and goes through a series of processes in our body. So the reason we get drunk and happy and carefree specifically comes down to what ethanol does to our neurotransminor systems. It stimulates the release of dopamine. It stimulates the release of endorphins, serotonin, all mood boosters, all associated with pleasure. And then it also enhances the activity of this one neurotransmitter. transmitter known as GABA. Now, GABA is an inhibitor. An inhibitor means that it has a really
因此，药物分为两种形式：抑制剂和兴奋剂。兴奋剂是像摇头丸或可卡因这样的东西。它们让我们更加活跃、充满活力和专注，而酒精则是一种抑制剂。它会减缓我们的脑电活动和动作。它能让我们不那么焦虑，因为它影响了我们身体与大脑之间传递信息的方式。所以，当我们喝一杯葡萄酒时，例如，这杯葡萄酒中包含的是乙醇。乙醇。乙醇是一种精神活性物质，会在我们体内进行新陈代谢，并在我们的体内经历一系列过程。所以，我们之所以会喝醉、感到快乐和无忧无虑，具体归结为乙醇对我们的神经递质系统做了什么。它刺激多巴胺的释放。它刺激内啡肽、血清素的释放，所有这些都是情绪增强剂，都与快乐有关。然后它还增强了一种特定神经递质的活动。
calming effect on the nervous system. That is what leads to the feelings of relaxation, reduced response times, and a confused state the more drunk we get. So the reason we like to drink is because biologically, psychologically, it makes us happy. It's really as simple as that. And psychology tells us through very simple principles of conditioning and learned association that when something makes us happy, we want to do it even more. So if it also removes a negative feeling at the same time, that makes it even more, I don't know, not addictive, but even more probable that we will continue to consume an amount that creates the same feeling again and again.
被称为GABA（γ-氨基丁酸）的神经递质。现在，GABA是一种抑制剂。抑制剂意味着它对神经系统有着非常平静的效果。这正是导致放松感、反应时间缩短的原因，而且我们喝得越醉，状态就会越混乱。所以我们喜欢喝酒的原因是，从生物学和心理学上讲，它让我们感到快乐。事情其实就是这么简单。心理学通过条件反射和习得性联结的非常简单的原理告诉我们，当某样东西让我们感到快乐时，我们会想要更多地去做它。因此，如果它同时还能消除一种负面情绪，那就更增加了——我不知道，倒不是说它成瘾，而是更有可能让我们继续消费能够一次又一次创造相同感觉的量。
it's interesting because a lot of things make us happy and aren't part of our daily lives. I like to use kind of like heroin as an example. Obviously it's a very drastic example, but we don't go and do heroin at a party or at a casual dinner. Maybe you do. I don't know. That is your prerogative. I don't think alcohol is your main concern. But the reason we don't go and do these drugs that make us feel just, as good if not better, is because it's not socially acceptable. Alcohol is not only socially acceptable. It is commonplace. It's celebrated. It's really positively viewed. So for centuries and
这很有趣，因为很多事情都能让我们快乐，但却不是我们日常生活的一部分。我喜欢用海洛因作为例子。显然这是一个非常极端的例子，但我们不会在聚会上或随意的晚宴上去吸海洛因。也许你会。我不知道。那是你的特权。我不认为酒精是你的主要担忧。但是，我们之所以不去服用那些能让我们感觉同样好甚至更好的药物，是因为这在社会上不可接受。酒精不仅在社会上可以接受。它是司空见惯的。它是被庆祝的。它是被非常正面地看待的。所以几个世纪以来，
centuries, humans have been using alcohol to change, elevate their mood. Even before we made it into a liquid form, people used to eat fermented fruits as a way to essentially get drunk because when things ferment or they rot, they produce that ethanol. So we can see really early signs of alcoholic beverages being used in that way across the world in Rome, in the Middle Ages, in ancient China, in Japan. Even beer back in the day was as commonplace as water. And nowadays, it's associated more so with celebration because if you're feeling really great about something, why not feel even better? Why not let alcohol amplify the mood? And then, of course, we can use it in the inverse situation.
人类一直在使用酒精来改变、提升他们的情绪。甚至在我们把它制成液体形式之前，人们就会吃发酵的水果作为一种基本上能喝醉的方法，因为当东西发酵或腐烂时，它们会产生乙醇。因此，我们可以在世界各地（在罗马、中世纪、古代中国、日本）很早就看到含酒精饮料被以这种方式使用的迹象。甚至在过去，啤酒也像水一样司空见惯。而如今，它更多地与庆祝联系在一起，因为如果你对某事感觉非常好，为什么不感觉更好呢？为什么不让酒精放大这种情绪呢？然后，当然，我们可以在相反的情况下使用它。
When our mood is low, when we're anxious, bored, that's a really big one. When we're depressed, we're lonely. Alcohol is a substance which can distract us from those feelings or put us temporarily in a better mood by creating artificial euphoria. So they conducted this review in 2022 and they found that alcohol is used in this way to suppress negative feelings more commonly than any other substance. And it's known as self-medicating. So self-medicating is when you use some kind of substance, activity, behavior, normally a drug of some sort, to almost minimize negative emotions and try and shift your mood back to a positive point.
当我们的情绪低落、感到焦虑、无聊时——这是一个非常大的因素，当我们感到沮丧、孤独时。酒精是一种可以让我们转移对这些负面情绪的注意力，或者通过产生人工欣快感而暂时让我们情绪变好的物质。因此，他们在2022年进行了一项评估，发现酒精被用于这种抑制负面情绪的频率比任何其他物质都高。这就是所谓的自我治疗。所以自我治疗是指你使用某种物质、活动、行为（通常是某种药物），来几乎将负面情绪降到最低，并试图将你的情绪拉回到积极的状态。
And the reason alcohol is used so commonly is because it's so widely available. However, whilst it may spike your mood for a while, the problem is that if you want to keep up those lively spirits, you have to keep drinking. And if you stop, those emotions and feelings come back stronger than ever. And they also come back in the form of a hangover, anxiety, a depressed mood. So what do we do in response? Well, we start drinking again and we drink more in order to cope. When that is prolonged, I don't think need to say it, but it results in a huge cost to our personal lives, our relationships, poorer fitness, health problems, reduced concentration. Obviously, self-medication and an addiction are very different things. That's incredibly important to remember. But it can quickly become
酒精之所以被如此普遍地使用，是因为它随处可见。然而，虽然它可能会在一段时间内让你的情绪高涨，但问题在于，如果你想保持那种活跃的精神状态，你就必须继续喝。如果你停下来，那些情绪和感觉就会卷土重来，甚至比以往更加强烈。而且它们还会以宿醉、焦虑、抑郁情绪的形式卷土重来。那我们该如何应对呢？好吧，我们开始再次喝酒，为了应对而喝得更多。当这种情况长期持续时，我想我不需要多说，它会导致对我们个人生活、人际关系、体能变差、健康问题、注意力减退的巨大代价。显然，自我治疗和成瘾是两码事。记住这一点极其重要。但如果我们无法找到更可持续、更健康的应对机制，它就会迅速演变成
addiction if we're not able to find more sustainable, healthy mechanisms for coping. So there was a one study published in 2019. It found that replacing alcohol in a self-medicating form, with something healthier that doesn't rely on a substance is incredibly hard to do, mainly because a lot of people don't even realize that they are self-medicating. We don't even know that the reason we have a glass of wine is because we're bored. The reason that we're drinking beer is because we're socially anxious. The reason that we're doing shots is because we want to get over our ex. That is all self-medicating. And it's so second nature. We are so in denial of what we're really trying to achieve by drinking. Obviously, that is not always the case, but it is another explanation
成瘾。因此，2019年发表的一项研究发现，用不依赖于某种物质的更健康的方法来取代自我治疗形式中的酒精是极其困难的，主要是因为许多人甚至没有意识到他们是在自我治疗。我们甚至不知道我们喝一杯葡萄酒是因为我们感到无聊。我们喝啤酒是因为我们社交焦虑。我们喝烈酒是因为我们想忘掉前任。这些全都是自我治疗。而且这太像第二天性了。我们对于自己通过饮酒真正想要达到的目的处于彻底的否定状态。显然，情况并不总是如此，但这又是为什么酒精被如此广泛使用的另一种解释。还有一个情况，而且我已经提到过好几次了，酒精也增强了我们的社交能力。正如人们所称的那样，它是一种社交润滑剂。它是自信的灵药。它让你觉得自己很强大。它让你感觉不那么缺乏安全感。所以类似于对其中一些黑暗思想的压制，它也提升了你认为别人会觉得更享受的那一部分自我。TikTok上有一位了不起的创作者，
for why alcohol is used so widely. It's also the case, and I've mentioned this a few times, alcohol increases our sociability as well. It's a social lubricant, as people call it. It's the elixir of confidence. It makes you feel powerful. It makes you feel less insecure. So similar to this suppression of some of those darker thoughts, it also elevates the part of you that you think others are going to find more enjoyable. There is this amazing creator on TikTok, and I cannot remember their name, but I'll leave it in the description. And they talk a lot about this as a neurodivergent person, whereby they use alcohol to feel more comfortable in social situations. It has become somewhat of a crutch for them as a way to fit in because it minimizes all of that social anxiety that
我记不得他们的名字了，但我会把它留在简介里。他们作为一个神经多样性的人，谈论了很多关于这一点的内容，即他们利用酒精在社交场合中感到更舒适。这在某种程度上成了他们的一个拐杖，作为一种融入群体的方式，因为它最大限度地减少了所有那些通常会把他们紧紧裹在壳里的社交焦虑。所以当我们把它分解开来时，我们通常不质疑饮酒习惯的原因是酒精让我们感觉良好。它是社会可接受的。它是泛滥的。所以即使我们没有有意识地意识到这一点，其中也涉及一些潜意识的文化同辈压力。然后当然，酒精可以作为应对许多内部问题或感觉的应对策略，一种对自己感觉更好的方式。那么，面对这些所谓的“好处”，停止饮酒的一些理由是什么呢？首先，我真的、真的认为我们应该考虑戒酒，或者至少如果我们只是想看看自己能不能做到的话，把饮酒量降到最低。不需要有比这更深层的理由。除此之外，这只是一项针对你的个人
would normally keep them very much in their shell. So when we break it down, the reason we often don't question our drinking habits is because alcohol makes us feel good. It's socially acceptable. It's prolific. So even if we're not consciously aware of it, there is some subliminal cultural peer pressure involved. And then of course, alcohol can be used as a coping strategy for so many internal problems or feelings, a way to feel better about who we are. So what are some of the reasons to stop in the faceable of these quote-unquote benefits? Firstly, I really, I really think that we should consider quitting or at least minimizing our drinking if you just want to see if you can. There doesn't need to be a deeper reason than that. Other than that is a personal
挑战。并且你想要真正评估自己是否能够做到这一点，或者这是否是一个更深层的问题。你想要测试自己依赖性的本质。即使只是持续一个月，我认为你也会看到一些非常巨大的改变。你会睡得更好。你的脑雾会减少，你会感觉体能更好，你的皮肤会改善，你肯定能省下钱，那是肯定的。对于二十几岁的许多人来说，酒精是一笔巨大的开支。一些估计甚至表明，如果你一周有四天、每次喝三杯酒，你每年至少可以节省8000美元。这就好比是一次免费的假期，就隐藏在你的戒酒中。此外，也许是最大的非健康相关原因，你将向自己证明
challenge for you. And you want to actually evaluate whether you're able to do it or whether this is a deeper problem. You want to test the nature of your reliance. Even if it's just for a month, I think you'll see some really huge changes. You will sleep better. You will have less brain fog, you'll feel fitter, your skin will improve, you'll definitely save money, that is for sure. Alcohol is such an expense for a lot of people in their 20s. Some estimates even suggest that you could save at least $8,000 a year if you are having three drinks, four days a week. That is like a free vacation right there, like hiding in your sobriety. And additionally, perhaps the biggest non-health related reason, you'll just prove to your self.
你能够做到。你将有机会体验一种没有酒精的生活。你可以为自己设定一个短期目标，一个需要纪律和暂时改变生活方式的目标，并致力于它。我认为这表明、向你自己证明了真正的精神力量，尤其是在面对大量社会压力的时候。这给了你一个为自己感到骄傲的理由，但它也表明你确实对这些有时是自动发生的行为（比如晚餐时喝一杯酒或每个周末喝酒）拥有有意识的控制权。你戒酒或只是减少消费的时间越长，好处就越大。我甚至无法开始列举那些向我们展示每周饮酒少于五杯的人的研究和健康文章的数量，
that you can. You get to trial a life without alcohol. You can set yourself a short-term goal, one that requires discipline and temporary lifestyle changes, and be committed to it. And I think that demonstrates that proves to yourself real mental strength, especially in the face of a lot of social pressure. It gives you a reason to feel proud of yourself, but it also demonstrates that you do have conscious control over these sometimes automatic behaviours, like having a glass of wine with dinner or drinking every weekend. And the longer that you abstain or just reduce your consumption, the greater the benefits become. I cannot even begin to list the amount of studies and health articles showing us that those of us who drink less than five drinks a week,
所以甚至不是完全戒酒，他们降低了患癌症、高血压、心脏病、肝损伤的风险，所有这些都是过量饮酒的长期副作用。我们来谈谈过量饮酒（或者至少是持续饮酒）的短期负面影响，如果你开始重新审视自己与酒精的关系，你将能够避免这些影响。对我来说，最大的一点就是宿醉和焦虑，本质上，这是我们二十几岁时一种普遍的经历。当我们饮酒过量、喝得烂醉时，我们基本上是在通过摄入更多的精神活性物质——乙醇，超过我们身体能够处理的量，来毒害我们的身体。这就是为什么当我们感到非常
so not even completely abstaining, reduce their risk of cancer, high blood pressure, heart disease, liver damage, all of which are really long-term side effects of excessive alcohol consumption. Let's also talk about the short-term downsides of drinking excessively, or at least consistently, that you're going to avoid if you start rethinking your relationship with alcohol. The biggest one to me is hangovers and anxiety, essentially, such a universal experience of our 20s. When we drink to the point of excess of being really drunk, what we are basically doing is poisoning our body by putting in more. of a psychoactive substance, ethanol, then our bodies can process. This is why when we feel really
醉时，我们经常觉得需要呕吐。这字面意思就是我们的身体在说：我正在中毒，我无法在不造成伤害的情况下处理所有这些，我需要把这些排出去，否则。饮酒后呕吐是身体清除有害物质的自然方式。而第二天早上，我们将感受到它的影响。当我们的身体代谢酒精时，它会释放出一种导致恶心、头痛和整体不适感的物质。它还会使我们的血糖水平飙升。它会导致我们脱水，干扰我们的睡眠。
drunk, we often feel the need to vomit. This is literally our body saying, I am being poisoned, I cannot process all of this without it doing harm, I need to expel this or else. Throwing up, vomiting after drinking alcohol is the body's natural way of removing what is actually a harmful material. And the next morning, we're going to feel the impact of that. Where, When our body metabolizes alcohol, it releases this substance that contributes to feelings of nausea, headaches, overall discomfort. It also spikes our blood sugar levels. It causes us to be dehydrated, interferes with our sleep.
这就是我们开始遇到一些心理和精神副作用的时候。其中一部分就是焦虑。我知道我们都经历过这种情况。第二天早上醒来，感觉自己的精神在螺旋式下降。担心自己说过或做过什么，有着这种看似没有特定原因的焦虑思维模式，感到偏执和一种厄运临头的感觉，这对我来说太普遍了。而真正促成我对无酒精充满好奇的主要因素之一是，
That's when we start to encounter some of those psychological and mental side effects as well. Part of that is anxiety. I know that we've all experienced this. Waking up the next morning, feeling like you're in a mental spiral. worrying about what you've said or done, having this seemingly unspecified, anxious pattern of thoughts, feeling paranoid and impending sense of doom, this is so commonplace for me. And one of the major factors that really contributed to my sober curiosity was,
我不想醒来时去想前一天晚上自己说过的话里有哪些是后悔的。我不想让那种混乱进入我的生活。当我们审视科学，尤其是脑科学时，焦虑与我们之前讨论过的神经递质GABA直接相关。它可能会让我们感觉更放松。但随着你继续饮酒，你的大脑也会开始关闭这种被称为谷氨酸的荷尔蒙、这种神经化学物质。这就是为什么我们感到非常平静。我们感到自由。我们感到更加自然。但它们是短暂的，因为随着酒精效力的消退，你的大脑需要恢复正常的化学平衡。它通过减少GABA（从而减少平静的感觉）并再次让谷氨酸飙升来做到这一点，当你试图回到那个平衡点时，这会让你更加焦虑。
I didn't want to wake up and think about everything that I regretted saying the night before. I didn't kind of want that chaos in my life. when we look at the science, particularly the brain science, anxiety is directly related to that neurotransmitter GABA that we were speaking about before. It might make us feel more relaxed. But as you continue drinking, your brain also starts to shut off this hormone, this neurochemical called glutamate. So that is why we feel really calm. We feel free. We feel more natural. but they're short-lived because as the alcohol wears off, your brain needs to restore that normal chemical balance. And it does this by reducing gabber, so reducing the calm feelings and spiking that glutamate again, making you more anxious as it tries to get you back to that point of balance.
所以我觉得，不断增加的宿醉和焦虑水平，这些都是考虑限制、减少饮酒的一些最大论据，特别是如果你是那种喝一杯、喝一瓶啤酒就停不下来的人。第二天总是被打乱。你无法完成那么多工作。你得去进行道歉之旅。确保你没有让自己出丑。你的身体就是感觉不太对劲。
So I think both, you know, an increasing level of hangovers and anxiety, those are some of the biggest arguments for considering a limit. a reduction to your drinking, especially if you are someone who has one glass, one beer, and can't stop. The next day is always disrupted. You can't get as much done. You have to do the apology tour. Make sure you haven't embarrassed yourself. Your body just doesn't feel quite right.
如果你是一个想要在生活中做出改变、拥有一些宏大目标的人，想要优先考虑进行身体锻炼并把事情做好，做一个早起的人，或者仅仅是一个好朋友，有时我们会意识到酒精和那些更广泛的价值观与目标并不吻合。它们是直接对立的。正是在这个时候，你真的需要考虑如何与这种物质建立更健康的关系。你的生活中如果没有酒精会是什么样？酒精少一点会是什么样？如果有改善的话，你却不做出改变，这在某种程度上是不理智的，因为你向自己展示了尽管
And if you are someone who wants to make changes in your life and has some big goals, wants to prioritize being physically active and getting shit done, being an early riser, or just a good friend, sometimes we come. to realize that alcohol and those broader values and goals, they don't align. They are in direct opposition. And it's at this point that you really need to consider how you can build a healthier relationship with this substance. What would your life look like without alcohol in it? What would it look like with less alcohol? If there would be an improvement, I think it's somewhat irrational that you don't make that change because you are showing to yourself that despite
有所有的好处，你出于某种原因仍然深受这种物质的控制。无论原因是什么，你本质上是在用酒精作为自我破坏的一种方式，你阻碍了自己过上更高质量的生活，而且你可能实际上对这种行为的控制力比你最初想象的要少。戒酒的另一个理由是，你将能够发现真实的自己，而不需要将酒精作为社交润滑剂。它会向你展示，即使你没有喝醉，你也可以玩得很开心。它会向你展示谁想要陪伴在你身边，
all the benefits, you're still very much under the thumb of this substance for some reason. Whatever that may be, you're essentially using alcohol as a way to self-sabotage, you are standing in your own way of a better quality of life, and it could be possible that you actually have less control over this behaviour than you initially believed. Another reason to quit drinking is that you're going to be able to discover who you truly are without using alcohol as a social lubricant. It will show you that you can have fun even if you're not drunk. it will show you who wants to be around you,
即使你没有微醺、没有妙语连珠、没有说些怪话。它会向你展示，保持清醒并不是一件扫兴的事，人们其实相当包容。这也意味着你在选择如何娱乐时必须更有创意。你可以去上艺术课、看电影、去攀岩，而且你可以开车去那里，而不是只选择出去喝一杯这个最轻松的选项。
even if you're not buzzed and funny and saying weird shit. It will show you that sobriety isn't a buzzkill, that people are quite accepting. And it also means that you have to be more creative and how you choose to have fun. Instead of just choosing the easiest option of going out for a drink, you can go to an art class, a movie, you can go rock climbing, and you can drive there.
你可以当指定代驾。每个人都喜欢指定代驾。显然，这只是有限的一些理由，其中一些可能并不像其他理由那样真正激励你，无论是出于心理益处、身体益处、社交益处，还是向自己证明你能做到的个人价值益处，有如此多的理由是如此具有说服力，但这些是真正突出的几点。我也认为，显然我们在讨论戒酒，但选择适度饮酒也同样有效且重要，同样强大，尽管它可能不像那么剧烈的改变，
You can be the designated driver. Everyone loves a designated driver. obviously this is a limited number of reasons and some of them may not really motivate you as much as the others do whether it's for mental benefits physical benefits social benefits just a personal value benefit of showing yourself that you can do it there are so many reasons that are so persuasive but these are the ones that really stick out i also think that obviously we're discussing quitting drinking but the decision to moderate your drinking is just as valid and important, just as powerful, even though it might not be as much of a drastic change,
但就你的健康而言，任何改变都是好的改变，即使你只是对无酒精感到好奇。我认为重要的是，对于任何自动的或社会条件化行为，我们实际上都要评估我们拥有多少控制权、我们参与的理由是什么，以及我们是否仍然接受由此带来的后果，是否对我们有更好的选择，即使它不是现状。然而，在这个决策过程中包含了一系列障碍，
any change is good change when it comes to your health, even if you are just sober curious. I think it's important that with any automatically or socially conditioned behavior, we actually evaluate how much control we have, our reasons for partaking, and whether we are still okay with the consequences of that, whether there is a better option for us, even if it's not the status quo. I think contained in that decision-making process, though, are a number of barriers,
尤其是关于我们会放弃什么的障碍。戒酒，决定限制饮酒，我想我们都明白这将是困难的，正是这种困难，正是对这种不适和困难的恐惧，让我们陷入这种行为或沉思阶段。我们害怕改变会让我们付出代价。我们害怕可能会失去朋友，害怕生活会变得无聊，害怕我们会怀念那种味道、那种感觉。
especially around what we would be giving up. Abstaining, deciding to limit, I think we understand that it will be difficult, and it's that difficulty, it's that fear of that discomfort and that difficulty that keeps us stuck in this behavior or in the contemplation stage. We fear what a change will cost us. We fear the friends we may lose, that life might be boring, that will miss the taste, the feeling.
所以接下来我要讨论的是一些挑战，以及如何克服它们。如果你对这感兴趣的话，我有一些将无酒精好奇融入你生活的建议。所有这些以及更多内容，都在这段简短的广告之后。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，
So what I want to discuss next are some of the challenges, but also how to overcome them. My tips for kind of integrating sober curiosity into your life if that's something that you're interested in. So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上具有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。英文是T-W-O-Percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小肯姆（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at it）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集节目中，我们都会来到这里，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那一切的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的快克毒品。需要明确的是，84年对我很重大，不仅仅是因为犯罪。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crime.
快克。我随时都能谈论快克，但只是想让你们大家知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你补充完那句话。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？
crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
瘾。我随时可以聊聊毒品的话题，但大家得知道我的意思，马克，这是我们讨论毒品的第二期节目了。所以我开始发现这其中有一条主线。我们现在也正在讨论艾滋病的话题。谢谢你帮我把话说完。我认为没有比这对于黑人来说更重要的一年了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
是的。对黑人来说，这是美国历史上最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听回顾节目。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师
Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
Kear Games。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多优秀嘉宾的对话带给大家。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession
我说的就是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会全心投入到追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了
of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
那样东西，但我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌。生活成了输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose.
你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。完全正确。这也是两个不同的信任层次。我希望你能真正做一个好人。和我（Kear Gaines）一起，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
On my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中。打开免费的IHeart Radio应用，搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露了她陈述中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的诉讼之战，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吧？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格（Greg），这位女同性恋，以及迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，
podcasts. What I've realized is that all the reasons why we choose to drink are the reasons why it's so hard to stop. Alcohol tastes good. Everyone else is drinking. It makes me feel better. It's an important part of celebrating with friends and family. It makes me more confident.
这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。我意识到，我们选择喝酒的所有原因，正是戒酒如此困难的原因。酒精尝起来很好。其他人都在喝。它让我感觉更好。这是与朋友和家人庆祝的重要部分。它让我更自信。
Those are just a few. And maybe that's an obvious statement. But ironically, the reason it's so hard to quit drinking is because it makes us feel so good. Because it is, as we've spoken about, a drug. It produces a lot of the chemistry in our brain that is associated with pleasure. When we drink regularly as well, our brains get used to elevated dopamine levels. And that is where our tolerance comes from. So when we make the decision to reduce or stop entirely, we are going to experience a drop in a lot of
这些只是其中几个原因。也许这是一个显而易见的陈述。但具有讽刺意味的是，戒酒之所以如此困难，是因为它让我们感觉太好了。正如我们所讨论的，因为它是一种药物。它在我们大脑中产生了许多与快乐相关的化学物质。当我们经常喝酒时，我们的大脑也会习惯升高的多巴胺水平。这就是我们耐受力的来源。因此，当我们决定减少饮酒或完全戒酒时，我们将经历大量
that artificially induced euphoria and happiness that we're experiencing that we've come to rely on. The thing I always will have been questioning a lot recently, though, is, is that actually real happiness? Is that a genuine feeling of happiness? Or is it just a chemical reaction produced by alcohol? So one of the biggest reasons I had for not quitting was alcohol is just so much fun. What if I'm boring without it? What if my life, is just less enjoyable. What am I going to do on those nights when a drink would, unfortunately, make me happier? A lot of this is tied up in emotion, but equally in a fear of change. Change is really scary, especially if you are someone like me for whom alcohol is such a normal part of everyday life.
我们一直以来依赖的、那些人工诱导的欣快感和幸福感的下降。然而，我最近一直在思考的一个问题是：这真的是真正的幸福吗？这是一种真正的幸福感吗？还是仅仅由酒精产生的化学反应？因此，我不戒酒的最大原因之一就是酒精太有趣了。如果我没有了它会变得很无聊怎么办？如果我的生活变得不那么有趣了怎么办？那些本来可以通过喝酒让我更开心的夜晚，我该怎么办？其中很多都与情感有关，但同样也与对改变的恐惧有关。改变真的很可怕，尤其是如果你像我一样，酒精已经成了日常生活如此正常的一部分。
It has been since I was 18, maybe even younger. So imagining life without it comes with a lot of unknowns. It comes with a lot of fear and humans naturally fear uncertainty or any sense of change, anything that disrupts what they're used to. It also requires a lifestyle adjustment that maybe we don't feel prepared to make because the effort required or the secondary impacts on other areas or domains of our lives seem too large. There's this really valuable psychological theory that we really should discuss here actually, and it's called the theory of behavior change or the stages of behavior change. When we are in the process of making a decision like abstaining from alcohol, we go through a series of chapters, a series of stages. Firstly, we have pre-contemplation. This is where we are not even thinking about it.
自从我18岁以来就一直是这样，甚至可能更小的时候就是。因此，想象没有它的生活会伴随着很多未知。它伴随着很多恐惧，人类天生害怕不确定性或任何意义上的改变，任何破坏他们习惯的东西。它还需要生活方式的调整，而我们可能觉得自己还没有准备好去做，因为所需的努力或对我们生活其他领域或方面的次要影响似乎太大了。这里有一个非常宝贵的心理学理论，我们真的应该在这里讨论一下，它被称为行为改变理论或行为改变阶段。当我们处于做出类似戒酒这样的决定的过程中时，我们会经历一系列的章节，一系列的阶段。首先，我们处于前沉思期。在这个阶段，我们甚至没有考虑过它。
We're not thinking about changing. We don't see any problem. We're happy to continue. then we might get to the contemplation stage. We're thinking about the pros and cons of quitting. We're not quite ready to do it, but it's definitely on our mind. It's definitely something that we're considering. Then we move to preparation. We know it's time to make a choice, to make a change, to make a shift. We begin to plan.
我们没有考虑改变。我们看不到任何问题。我们很高兴继续保持现状。然后我们可能会进入沉思阶段。我们正在考虑戒酒的利弊。我们还没完全准备好这样做，但它绝对在我们的脑海里。这绝对是我们正在考虑的事情。然后我们进入准备阶段。我们知道是时候做出选择、做出改变、做出转变了。我们开始计划。
We begin to make contingencies like, okay, I'm going to go sober next month. This is how I'm going to do it. And then we have action. This is where we actually do it. This is the fourth stage. And finally, after that, maintenance. We've quit. We're not going back.
我们开始制定应急计划，比如，好吧，我下个月要戒酒。这就是我要怎么做。然后我们采取行动。这是我们真正付出行动的阶段。这是第四阶段。最后，在此之后是维持阶段。我们已经戒了。我们不会回头。
Sometimes we cycle through these stages again and again, either because we're not committed to full sobriety or because we're still trying to find the willpower to adjust and go through with it, switching between contemplation and preparation, contemplation and preparation again and again and again. That's totally okay. This theory shows us this is part of the cycle. At that moment when we're really considering maybe some of the downsides of quitting,
有时我们会一遍又一遍地经历这些阶段，要么是因为我们没有完全致力于彻底戒酒，要么是因为我们仍在努力寻找调整并坚持到底的意志力，在沉思和准备之间反复切换，一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍。这完全没关系。这个理论表明，这是这个循环的一部分。在那一刻，当我们真正考虑戒酒的一些负面影响时，
like what we're going to miss out on, we are in the contemplation stage. We know that it might be good for us. We know the benefits, but once again, there is either a fear or something else holding us back. And aside from the pure happiness factor, the second biggest contributor is social acceptance. I was speaking about this on Instagram the other day and I asked you guys would you be able to quit drinking? Yes, no, maybe.
比如我们会错过什么，我们正处于沉思阶段。我们知道这对我们有好处。我们知道它的好处，但再次说明，要么是出于恐惧，要么是其他什么东西在阻碍我们。除了纯粹的快乐因素之外，第二个最大的促进因素是社会接受度。我前几天在Instagram上谈到这个时，我问大家：你们能戒酒吗？能，不能，也许吧。
If you were, if you answered no, sorry, if you said you couldn't quit drinking, why is that? Every single one of you said this. There was probably two out of like 200 responses that didn't say alcohol is so socially ingrained in my life. It is so omnipresent. What am I going to be?
如果你，如果你回答不能，抱歉，如果你说你戒不了酒，为什么会这样？你们每个人都这么说。在大概200条回复中，可能只有两条没有说“酒精已经深深融入了我的社会生活。它无处不在。如果我不喝酒，我会有什么损失吗？”
miss out on if I don't drink. What are my friends going to think? Am I going to feel left out or miss out on like those drunk memories? Here's my response to that. Firstly, the memories you make when you're drunk are not actually great memories, mainly because alcohol interrupts our ability to consolidate the things that we're experiencing and turn them into memories. So a lot of the time, what we think we remember is not even what we remember. There's really a lot of points of confusion or blackout in that. Secondly, the people you lose, if it comes to that, I don't think it will. They were not around you for the right reasons. And there are so many substitutions these days for alcohol like mocktiles and like alcohol-free liquors and soft drink. The mere fact that
如果我不喝，我会错过什么？我的朋友们会怎么想？我会觉得自己被冷落或错过那些醉酒的记忆吗？以下是我对此的回应：首先，当你喝醉时留下的记忆其实并不是什么好记忆，主要是因为酒精打断了我们巩固正在经历的事情并将其转化为记忆的能力。所以很多时候，我们以为自己记住的甚至都不是我们真正记住的。其中确实有很多混乱或断片的地方。其次，如果你失去了一些朋友，如果事情发展到那一步的话，我觉得不会。他们原本也不是为了正确的原因才留在你身边。如今，对于酒精有那么多的替代品，比如无酒精鸡尾酒、无酒精烈酒和软饮料。仅仅因为
your beverage is not alcoholic is not going to dramatically shift your relationships, at least not the ones that matter, at least not the ones with the people who are really important. If anything, I think you'll find that your relationships will actually deepen because you will be more alert, a better listener, you won't say things you regret, you'll find other ways to hang out with your friends without alcohol being at the centre. Just because alcohol and drinking are convenient and socially acceptable options doesn't mean they are the best options, especially when we focus on the positives and the upsides of limiting our intake. And you can still have fun. I think the mere fact that you're worried you won't be able to is another reason to actually rethink your reliance on
你的饮料不含酒精，并不会戏剧性地改变你的人际关系，至少不会改变那些重要的人际关系，至少不会改变那些真正重要的人的关系。如果有的话，我想你会发现你们的关系实际上会加深，因为你会更加警觉，成为一个更好的倾听者，不会说出让自己后悔的话，你会找到其他方式和朋友聚会，而不需要把酒精放在中心。仅仅因为酒精和饮酒是方便且社会可接受的选择，并不意味着它们就是最好的选择，尤其是当我们专注于限制摄入量的积极面和好处时。你仍然可以玩得很开心。我认为，仅仅是你担心自己做不到这一点，就是重新考虑你对酒精依赖的另一个原因。
alcohol. Because if you are relying on it as a crutch in order to socialize or be funnier, more charismatic, is it actually you in those moments or is it the alcohol that people like? Once again, who would you be without alcohol? Would you be healthier, happier, fitter, more confident? These reasons all sound really worth it. I want to class. clarify here. I am in no way is completely sober. I still drink, but since reflecting on the role that this plays in my life, I've massively reduced how much I consume and more conscious of my decisions towards drinking. I've gone from drinking maybe every night to just weekends or special occasions, holidays, and definitely not to the same level as before, where it was like alcohol was
因为如果你把它当作拐杖来社交、或者让自己变得更有趣、更有魅力，那么在那些时刻，真正受欢迎的是你，还是酒精？再次问问自己，如果没有酒精，你会是谁？你会更健康、更快乐、身材更好、更自信吗？这些理由听起来真的很值得。我在这里澄清一下。我绝不是完全戒酒了。我还在喝酒，但自从反思了酒精在我的生活中所扮演的角色后，我大大减少了消费量，并且对饮酒的决定有了更多的意识。我从可能每天晚上喝酒变成只在周末或特殊场合、节假日喝酒，而且绝对没有达到以前那种程度——当时酒精
just such a fixture in my life, right? Like it was just such a huge part of who I chose to be. And it was scary seeing who that version of me would be without it. I want to discuss some tips for my sober curious listeners out there who are maybe in the contemplation preparation stage. First of all, get clear on the why. Everyone is going to have unique reasons, whether it is for physical health, mental well-being to save money, to test mental strength. Make sure you are certain of your motivations because they are what will keep you committed. and start doing your own research on the benefits. Follow people on a similar journey who maybe are also sober curious,
简直是我生活中的一个固定设施，对吧？就像它是我选择成为的人的很大一部分一样。看到没有那个版本的自己会是什么样子，这让人感到害怕。我想为那些处于沉思/准备阶段的“对戒酒好奇”的听众分享一些建议。首先，搞清楚为什么。每个人都有独特的理由，无论是为了身体健康、心理健康、省钱，还是为了测试心理力量。确保你坚信自己的动机，因为它们将是你坚持下去的动力。并开始自己研究这些好处。关注那些有着类似经历的人，他们可能也对戒酒感到好奇，
who are also just dead sober, who are not kind of participating in the alcohol culture, the same way that you would like to not participate. Surround yourself with people who may be willing to try as well, who are already in the action phase. Keep those incentives and motives front and center at all times. set short-term goals first as well. One of the biggest mistakes people make when they set out to change their lives or at least some component of it is that they go all in all at once.
他们也可能已经完全戒酒，不参与那种你不想参与的酒精文化。让自己周围的人也愿意尝试，或者那些已经处于行动阶段的人。时刻把这些激励因素和动机放在最显眼的位置。首先也要设定短期目标。人们在着手改变生活或至少改变其中某一部分时，犯的最大错误之一就是一下子全部投入。
They adopt an all-or-nothing approach, which researchers, therapists, psychologists, they all say that is one of the easiest ways to ensure that you fail. Because if we only accept perfection and complete adherence to our goals, we are neglected reality, specifically the reality that behavior change is hard because it requires us to revise a lot of what is automatic for us. Instead of going cold turkey, if you can, try not to drink every second day, then try not to drink during the week, then every second week, then challenge yourself to a month. Month-long sobriety challenges like dry July. They're a really good trial in this case where it's only 30 days. It's super doable. You don't have to
他们采取了非黑即白的态度，而研究人员、治疗师、心理学家都表示，这是确保你失败的最简单方法之一。因为如果我们只接受完美并且完全遵守目标，我们就是在忽视现实，特别是行为改变很难这一现实，因为它需要我们修正很多对我们来说是自动化的行为。如果可以的话，不要一下子完全戒掉，先尝试每隔一天不喝酒，然后尝试在工作日不喝酒，然后每两周不喝酒，然后挑战自己一个月不喝酒。为期一个月的戒酒挑战，比如“干燥七月”（Dry July）。在这种情况下，这真的是一个很好的尝试，因为只有30天。这超级可行。你不需要
give up everything in your life, you have the promise of a finished date. And that can be something that really helps you. Sometimes what we actually see, though, with some of those like 30-day no alcohol challenges is what psychologists call rebound behaviours, where when we are allowed to drink again, we actually end up drinking more. But if we see this as part of a broader long-term shift to drinking less and we keep our motives up, we can normally avoid this. And if completely sobriety is not for you or not medically necessary. Try to keep drinking to just the weekends or big events. Stick to just one or two drinks. It might be less scary if you have a limit. You know, less scary if you're not completely cutting something out of your life, but more so integrating
放弃生活中的一切，你有一个明确的结束日期的承诺。这真的能帮到你。然而，有时我们在进行一些30天无酒精挑战时，实际上会看到心理学家所说的反弹行为，即当我们被允许再次喝酒时，我们最终实际上喝得更多了。但如果我们把这看作是减少饮酒的更广泛长期转变的一部分，并且我们保持动机，我们通常可以避免这种情况。如果完全戒酒不适合你，或者从医学角度来说并非必要。尽量把饮酒限制在周末或重大活动上。坚持只喝一两杯。如果你有一个限制，可能会不那么可怕。你知道的，如果你不是完全把某种东西从生活中切断，而是更多地将
non-alcoholy versions into how you socialize, integrating sobriety into how you see your life. small change once again better than no change additionally don't forget to reward yourself here you are really challenging yourself with this you should feel proud of your efforts a lot of people in their 20s of all ages are not considering this with each kind of milestone you hit each week that you stay sober each i don't know fortnight that you choose to not drink reward yourself with a little treat with a little Amazon purchase you really want, a little snack from the grocery store to keep up that positive reinforcement.
无酒精版本的饮品融入你的社交方式中，将戒酒融入你对生活的看法中，就不会那么可怕。小改变再次好过没有改变。此外，别忘了奖励自己，在这里你真的在用这个挑战自己，你应该为自己的努力感到骄傲。许多20多岁的人、各个年龄段的人都没有在考虑这一点。随着你达到的每一个里程碑、你保持戒酒的每一周、你选择不喝酒的每一个，我不知道，两周，用一点小小的奖励来犒劳自己，比如一个你一直想要的小小亚马逊购买物，或者杂货店里的一小份零食，来保持这种积极的强化。
I think also consistent reward can be helpful in counteracting some of the natural declines we're going to see in the pleasure that we may have been used to getting from alcohol. Instead of getting that dopamine hit and then immediate regret from over-drinking, you can receive that pleasure, that sense of satisfaction, that happiness, from a more positive and meaningful personal reward.
我认为持续的奖励也有助于抵消我们从酒精中习惯获得的快乐感的自然下降。与其获得多巴胺的冲击，然后因为饮酒过量而立即感到后悔，不如从一个更积极、更有意义的个人奖励中获得那种快乐、那种满足感、那种幸福感。
Finally, plan ahead when it comes to big social situations. We all know what it's like to feel FOMO, to feel pressure from those around us, maybe even anxiety because we're doing something a little bit different. And that can really cause us to give up because there is nothing as significant and influential as someone really trying to get you to to have a drink, to have a cocktail with them. So if you have a plan, you bring your own non-alcoholic beverages, you know that you're going to have one drink,
最后，在面对大型社交场合时要提前规划。我们都知道FOMO（错失恐惧症）是什么感觉，感受到来自周围人的压力，甚至因为我们做了一些有点不同的事情而感到焦虑。这真的会导致我们放弃，因为没有什么比一个真正试图让你喝酒、和你一起喝鸡尾酒的人更有影响力和影响力了。所以如果你有一个计划，带上你自己的无酒精饮料，你知道你只会喝一杯酒，
then only have like diet Coke or lemonade from there. You're going to feel more certain. You're going to feel more committed. You're going to feel more strong in the fact that you have made a decision for you and you are willing to see it through. I think beyond that, whether you are ready to quit drinking or just thinking about it, it's so important to think about how our behaviours may have. consequences for our well-being that we haven't been taught to consider, especially in societies
然后从那以后只喝健怡可乐或柠檬水。你会感到更确信。你会感到更坚定。你会因为自己为自己做出了一个决定并且愿意坚持到底而感到更加强大。我认为除此之外，无论你准备好戒酒还是只是在考虑它，思考我们的行为可能会对我们的幸福产生我们从未被教导去考虑的后果，这非常重要，尤其是在
where heavy excessive drinking is so normalized. Your health is the most important thing, period. And so maybe, you know, you might not have a problem at this point. You might never have a problem with alcohol. But it is worth questioning whether your life could be improved without it. It's not always about life just being pretty good. Could it be better? I'm also in this phase of really exploring this as well, you know, I'm still not sure I could ever go sober, and I think that that in itself requires its own unpacking, but I'm glad that I just stopped going along with what I'd begun to feel was normal. I'm glad that I actually, you know, took a step back and was like, is this actually hurting me or benefiting me? Which one of these is stronger here? How come it is so hard for me
过度饮酒如此正常化的社会中。你的健康是最重要的，句号。所以也许，你知道的，你目前可能没有问题。你可能永远不会对酒精有问题。但值得质疑的是，没有它，你的生活是否可以得到改善。这并不总是关乎生活是否相当不错。它能变得更好吗？我也处于真正探索这一阶段的过程中，你知道的，我仍然不确定自己是否能完全戒酒，我认为这本身就需要好好剖析一番，但我很高兴我不再随波逐流，不再顺从我开始觉得正常的事情。我很高兴我真的，你知道的，退后一步想：这到底是在伤害我还是在帮我？这两者哪个更强？为什么对我来说甚至很难
to even consider stopping. What does that say about my own mental strength and the power that this substance may have over me? What am I going to see in terms of my health and my well-being if I made this what could be a very small arbitrary decision? And it really hasn't, like, influenced my life as much as I thought it would. I really thought that, like, my social life would, you know, would end. It would cease.
考虑停下来。这说明了我自己的心理力量以及这种物质可能对我的控制力有什么？如果我做出这个可能非常微小的、随意的决定，我在健康和幸福方面会看到什么？它其实并没有像我想象的那样对我的生活产生那么大的影响。我真的以为，我的社交生活会，你知道的，就此结束。它会停止。
I would never see certain friends again, but it hasn't been like that. And hopefully it's a decision. I continue to make and continue to explore. So I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. I hope that it provided you with just something to think about or some motivation for something that you have been thinking about. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, if you think that there is a friend, family member,
我再也不会见到某些朋友了，但事实并非如此。希望这是一个我将继续做出并继续探索的决定。所以我真的希望你喜欢这一集。我希望它能为你提供一些思考的东西，或者为你一直在思考的事情提供一些动力。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，如果你认为有某个朋友、家人、
workmate, maybe not workmate, anybody though, who needs to hear this episode, please feel free to share it with them. Hopefully it will help them out as well. And leave a five-star review. If you've got something from this episode, make sure that you're following us to know when new episodes will come out. And if you have an episode suggestion, if maybe you want to follow up,
同事，也许不是同事，但任何人，需要听听这一集，请随时分享给他们。希望它也能对他们有所帮助。并留下五星好评。如果你从这一集里有所收获，请确保关注我们，以便了解新节目的发布时间。如果你有节目建议，或者想进行后续跟进，
if you are getting sober this year, if you're trying to drink less, congratulations. I would love to hear from you and maybe other things that you're doing on this kind of like journey, on this path. And congratulations as well. I think I already said that, but that is like amazing. So thank you again for tuning in. And we will be back next week with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all?
如果你今年正在戒酒，或者正试图减少饮酒，恭喜你。我很想听到你的消息，了解你在这个旅程、这条道路上正在做的其他事情。也再次恭喜你。我想我已经说过了，但这真的太棒了。所以再次感谢大家的收听。我们下周将带着另一集回归。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
you're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Gaines。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一副盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格（Greg），一个女同性恋。迈克尔·拉尼尼（Michael Ranini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura, Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWA% on the I-HeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你将会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人的身份从另一端走出来。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》？也就是TWA%。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。这是一档IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证纯人类制作。本集暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。